يحاول صادق الذي جاء من محافظه اب طلبا
للرزق ارسال ما جمعه من مال لاسرته لكن
فارقه صرف العمله بين مناطق سيطره الحكومه
الشرعيه والحوثيين يثقل كاهله يعني
باطل يعني الناس شاقين الان على العمله
الصرافين ماشي فايده تتعب تتعب واخر شيء
الدراسه مع حاله التفاؤل في الشارع اليمني
لانهاء الحرب تبقى المخاوف عند البعض
قائمه بالنسبه للسلام كل اليمني يطمحونه
الى السلام لكن نحن مجربين مع الحوثي
مسبقا انه لم يفض الوعود حقه يعني
لم يفتحها ولم ينفذ من الوعود التي وعدتها
شيئا لكن عندنا امان ان شاء الله سبحانه
وتعالى اذا اذا اجدوا اليمنيين وخلصت
النوايا سيتم السلام ان شاء الله
يترقب اليمنيون اعلان نتائج المباحثات
والخروج من دوامه الحرب والصراع وعوده
اللحمه المجتمعيه امال كبيره عند اليمنيين
ان تتوقف الحرب ويعم السلام وتفتح
الطرقاته بين المدن والمخاوف واحده وهي
عدم التزام الحوثيين بنتائج المباحثات
محمود الحميدي لقناه العربيه مارب
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات